Era una persona económicamente racional.
Le dijo a su amorcito: "Casémonos.
Unamos nuestros intereses".
(Risas)
Sí que lo hizo.
"Te quiero de verdad", dijo. "Profundamente, más que
a ninguna otra mujer con la que me haya encontrado.
Más que a Mary, Jane, Susie, Penélope,
Ingrid, Gertrude, Gretel...
por aquel entonces yo estaba en un programa de intercambio alemán". (Risas)
"Te quiero más que..."
¡Hasta ahí! Ella se fue de la habitación a mitad de la enumeración
de su amor por ella.
Después de recuperarse de su sorpresa, ya saben,
al ser rechazado, llegó a la conclusión de que había escapado por los pelos
de casarse con una persona irracional,
aunque, tomó nota, la próxima vez que
pidiera la mano, quizás no sería necesaria la enumeración
de todas las mujeres candidatas. (Risas)
Pero vale como consejo. Debes buscar alternativas
para así encontrar tu destino.
¿O tienes miedo de la palabra "destino"?
¿Te asusta la palabra "destino"?
Eso es de lo que estamos hablando, y si no encuentras
la más alta expresión de tu talento, si tu meta
es un "interés", lo que demonios signifique eso,
¿sabes qué pasará al final de tu larga vida?
Tus amigos y familia se reunirán en el cementerio
y ahí, al lado de tu tumba habrá una lápida,
y grabado en ella se leerá:
"Aquí yace el distinguido ingeniero que inventó el velcro".
Pero lo que esa lápida debería haber dicho era,
en una vida alternativa,
lo que debería haber dicho si eso era la mayor expresión de
tu talento: "Aquí yace el último premio Nobel, laureado en física,
que formuló la Teoría de la Gran Unificación
y demostró la viabilidad del empuje por curvatura".
(Risas)
Velcro, en serio. (Risas)
Una fue una gran carrera.
La otra fue una oportunidad perdida.
Pero entonces, habrá algunos de ustedes,
que, a pesar de todas esas excusas, encontrarán,
encontrarán su pasión.
Y aún así fracasarán
Y fracasarán porque...
porque no van a hacerlo,
porque se inventarán una nueva excusa,
cualquier excusa para no actuar, y esta excusa
la he escuchando tantas veces.
"Sí, lucharía por una gran carrera, pero valoro
las relaciones humanas por encima de los éxitos.
Quiero ser un gran amigo. Quiero ser un gran cónyuge.
Quiero ser un gran padre, y no los sacrificaré
para conseguir el éxito".
(Risas)
¿Qué quieres que te diga?
¿De verdad, quieres que te diga, que te diga...?
"En serio, lo juro, no pego a los niños" (Risas)
¿Mmm? Mira la visión del mundo que te estás dando.
Eres un héroe de una forma u otra, y yo, sugiriendo,
tan delicadamente, que podrías querer una gran carrera,
debes odiar a los niños. No odio a los niños. Ni les pego.
Bueno, había un niño deambulando por el edificio
cuando llegué, y no, no le pegué. (Risas)
Eso sí, tuve que decirle que en el edificio solo podían entrar adultos
y que se fuera.
Murmuró algo sobré su madre.
y le respondí que probablemente la encontraría fuera.
La última vez que lo vi, estaba en las escaleras, llorando. (Risas)
Qué llorica. (Risas)
¿Pero qué quieres? Eso es lo que esperas de mí.
¿De verdad crees, de verdad, que es apropiado
que utilices a los niños
para que actúen como escudo?
¿Y sabes lo que te pasará algún día,
a ti, el padre perfecto?
Tu hijo vendrá algún día y te dirá:
"Ya sé lo que quiero ser.
Ya sé que voy a hacer con mi vida".
Estás tan feliz. Es la conversación
que todo padre quiere oír, porque tu hijo es bueno en matemática
y sabes lo que pasará a continuación.
Y tu hijo dice: "He decidido que
quiero ser mago.
Quiero hacer trucos de magia en el escenario".
(Risas)
¿Y qué respondes?
Le dices:
"Mmm... un poco arriesgado, hijo.
Puede que no salga. No se gana mucho, hijo.
Sabes, no estoy seguro, pero
creo que deberías pensártelo, hijo,
eres tan bueno en mate, ¿por qué no...?"
Y el niño te interrumpe y dice:
"Pero es mi sueño. Es mi sueño serlo".
¿Y qué le vas a decir?
¿Sabes que le vas a decir?
"Mira, hijo. Una vez, yo también tuve un sueño, pero... pero..."
¿Y cómo vas a terminar tu frase con un "pero"?
"...pero. Tuve un sueño también, una vez, hijo, pero tuve miedo de perseguirlo".
¿O le vas a decir esto?
"Una vez tuve un sueño, hijo...
pero entonces naciste tú". (Risas)
(Risas) (Aplausos)
De verdad, realmente quieres usar a tu familia,
quieres mirar a tu cónyuge,
a tus hijos, y ver a tus carceleros?
Hay algo que le podrías haber dicho a tu hijo
cuando él o ella dijera: "Tengo un sueño".
Podrías haber respondido, mirándole a la cara:
"Persíguelo, hijo,
igual que hice yo".
Pero no podrás decirlo
porque no lo hiciste. Así que no puedes. (Risas)
Y así los pecados de los padres
recaen sobre los pobres niños.
¿Por qué buscar refugio en las relaciones humanas
como excusa para no perseguir tu pasión?
Sabes por qué.
En el fondo de tu corazoncito, lo sabes,
y estoy hablando en serio.
Tú sabes por qué te sientes tan a gustito
y te escudas en las relaciones humanas.
Porque eres...
Tú sabes lo que eres.
Tienes miedo de perseguir tu pasión.
Tienes miedo de hacer el ridículo.
Miedo de intentarlo. Miedo de que puedas fallar.
Un gran amigo, gran cónyuge, gran padre, gran carrera.
¿No viene todo junto? ¿No es eso lo que eres?
¿Cómo puedes ser una cosa sin la otra?
Pero tienes miedo.
Y es por eso que no vas a tener una gran carrera, salvo que...
"salvo"... una de las palabras más evocadoras en inglés...
salvo.
Pero la palabra "salvo" también va unida
a esta otra frase, tan terrorífica:
"Si solo hubiera..."
Si alguna vez tienes ese pensamiento rondándote la cabeza,
te va a doler mucho.
Así que estas son las razones
de por qué no vas a
tener una gran carrera,
salvo que...
Salvo.
Gracias. (Aplausos)